por supuesto que sí de hecho esta zona
esta zona del país donde pasa el
terremoto antes del terremoto no se
podía pasar esta zona en la zona sur del
país estaba cortada por el país por las
bandas criminales que controlaban y
estas bandas criminales estamos hablando
a pocos a pocos kilómetros del palacio
presidencial
estamos hablando 15 kilómetros menos de
5 kilómetros del palacio presidencial
es el ejemplo de lo que sucedió con los
fondos enviados tras el terremoto de
2010 una de las razones de reticencia
internacional al envío de ayuda sobre
todo económicas el primer ministro ariel
a hoy y ya dijo que no se van a cometer
los mismos errores pero podría ser este
una razón también
la razón lo que la ayuda
anteriormente era gestionado por las
ongs y normalmente se sabe que el 90% de
estas ayudas los gestionan los jóvenes
es otra cosa también la inseguridad hace
que muchos de esos personales de los
ongs que as que estaban en el país ya no
están como que la comunidad
internacional es muy difícil existente
de encontrar una persona de cuánto para
entregar esos fondos y eso es otro
problema de la inseguridad también que
hace que no hay mucha presencia y qué
garantías puede dar el gobierno haitiano
para darle tranquilidad tanto a las ongs
como a los gobiernos de otros países a
que envíen esta ayuda y que la ayuda a
llegar a las personas que la necesitan
la garantía el gobierno lo está dando el
problema es que antes del terremoto
había parte esta parte particularmente
al gobierno no tenía control sobre este
esta parte del país el gobierno puede
decir que les voy a dar seguridad le va
a dar tal cosa inclusive esta mañana
mismo todavía
continúan
escena de secuestro en el mismo en la
misma ciudad en puerto príncipe las
bandas criminales siguen con los con las
actividades de secuestro y crea usted
que la situación que está viviendo
afganistán en estos momentos puede estar
quitándole recursos o atención a lo que
sucede ya lo que le está pasando al
pueblo de haití yo creo que si no
solamente lo que está pasando en
afganistán también en la situación de la
pandemia también muchos países tienen
mucho problema para resolver con la
pandemia y encima de eso lo de haití va
a pasar en un segundo plano no solamente
en lo de afganistán tanto también la
pandemia
pues muchísimas gracias a usted luis ya
el horizon que nos acompañaba desde
españa el es doctor en ciencias
políticas nos acompañaba para analizar
las situaciones de las posibles razones
que podrían estar ralentizando la
llegada de ayuda a haití tras el
terremoto que sucedió el sábado y que
deja ya más de 2.000 víctimas mortales